hier à valenciennes l'hospitalisation
d'une femme âgée de 40 ans a permis aux
gendarmes de découvrir au fond de son
jardin
le nouveau né qu'elle voulait abandonner
la petite fille prématurée va bien
depuis plusieurs années la belgique a
renoué avec une pratique ancestrale le
tiroir abb tiroirs de la honte pour
certains pour d'autres au contraire il
permet de sauver des vies l'une de nos
équipes s'est récemment rendu près
d'anvers ou un nouveau-né venait d'être
ainsi abandonné leur portage de gonzague
van damme et sébastien grax samedi 17
novembre
un peu avant midi une femme discrètement
dépose un bébé dans ce tiroir et s'en va
une alarme se déclenche et quelques
minutes plus tard une bénévole de
l'association découvre le petit garçon
âgé de quelques jours en vie pénible et
triste qu'on sait que cette maman a
vraiment dû se trouver dans des
conditions terribles avant de décider à
une solution
une fois que j'ai fermé s'est bloqué et
même la maman death et plus atteindre un
sommet des mâts ce moment là le bébé est
dans notre responsabilité dans le tiroir
une lettre destinée à la mer explique ce
que va devenir son enfant l'association
confie le bébé aux services sociaux
la mère a alors six semaines pour
changer d'avis et se manifester si elle
ne le fait pas l'abandon sera définitif
et son enfant déclaré adoptable
cette association d'anvers est près de
400 familles en difficulté c'est maman
qui viennent ici chercher de la
nourriture ou des soins passe
régulièrement devant le tiroir et cela
ne semble pas les choquer je pense que
c'est une bonne chose il y a sûrement
des mamans trion trop et c'est mieux que
de l'abandonner dans un sac poubelle ou
n'importe où
l'association d'anvers n'a rien inventé
les tiroirs où tour à bb existe en
europe depuis le moyen-âge celui-ci
exposé au musée de tournai a fonctionné
pendant près de 20 ans mille deux cents
enfants y ont été déposés pour être
abandonné ça a sauvé des polémiques
parce que les les partisans de ce tour
disait que ça les éviter les
infanticides les avortements
mais aussi la présence du tour suscité
des envies de semer conduit finalement à
la fin du 19e siècle
la polémique aura raison des tiroirs abb
un peu partout en europe
mais en 2000 une association allemande
en ouvre un hambourg depuis la paresse
dans de nombreux pays comme la suisse la
hongrie l'italie la france échappe à ce
phénomène grâce à sa loi autorisant
l'accouchement sous x
presque une exception en europe c'était
du belge a déposé un projet de loi
permettant d'accoucher dans l'anonymat
pour éviter au maire d'avoir abandonné
leurs enfants même dans un tiroir
il faut changer la loi et c'est vraiment
nécessaire de le faire les cons comme ça
on peut on peut enlever ce tilloy ddd
honte parce que pour moi c'est vraiment
un style voir donc
mais pour l'association d'anvers le
tiroir restera utile même si une loi est
votée on doit avoir une solution à
l'année pour qu au moins des bébés pour
l'instant le tiroir abb d'anvers est le
seul de belgique
inaugurée en 2000 il n'a servi qu'une
seule fois il une autre association
envisage d'en ouvrir à ostende
là où en octobre un bébé mort a été
retrouvé abandonné sur la plage